[Musique]
si je pouvais je voudrais bien sûr être
à la maison blanche dans la demeure
présidentielle lorsque dans notre
chambre à son téléphone lorsqu'ils
twitte pas pour le savoir à l'avancé
nécessairement mais surtout pour pouvoir
lui demander tout de suite après
pourquoi as tu écris ça pourquoi ces
mots là pourquoi avoir choisi de mettre
des guillemets à cet endroit d'autres
moi majuscule aussi vous le savez les
tweets du président font son sujet a
énormément d'interprétation ce serait
absolument fantastique de pouvoir lui
demander à lui directement mais qu'est
ce que vous avez voulu dire exactement
avec ses murs j'aimerais entrer
librement en corée du nord faire mon
travail de journaliste sans
l'encadrement qui réservé habituellement
par le régime qui veut diriger les
médias vers des scénarios des scènes
qu'il veut voir couvrir ça c'est un
souhait qui pour l'instant demeure
impossible voire irréel
si je peux rajouter un sérieusement ce
qui serait absolument fantastique c'est
de pouvoir faire un reportage sur la
désinformation aux états unis entre
autres
il ya des groupes de gens qui se disent
experts spécialistes qui vont dans des
petites villes dans des régions rurales
et qui répondent toutes sortes de
fausses informations sur les migrants
sous les musulmans c'est en partie comme
ça après que toutes sortes de préjugés
négatifs contre les musulmans contre
l'islam prennent racine aux états unis
ce qui est des présidents des populistes
des candidats des politiciens comme dans
l'autre on pas se faire élire de pouvoir
expliquer cette mécanique leur parler
aux gens qui s'aiment 7 des informations
ça serait un reportage qui est difficile
à faire mais je pense qu'il serait aussi
essentiel